joe biden is going to give a prime time
speech talking about how half the
country are an extreme threat to
democracy and this is
i honestly can't believe it i mean i i
mean i guess i can believe it this the
they started the live stream already
we're going to be hanging out we're
going to talk about what he's talking
about we're going to criticize it
obviously because it's already worthy of
criticism he's going to come out and say
trump supporters that you know what
trump represents is a threat to this
country and that represents a massive
portion of individuals in this country
considering
trump is pulling ahead of joe biden
this is
man it's it's getting crazy in this
country we've got the new york post
reporting that trump could be facing you
know obstruction of justice charges
newsweek saying multiple felonies
they've arrested the lawyer for the oath
keepers the new york times is saying
they're going to go after trump's
lawyers let me tell you man when it gets
to the point where they're going after
the lawyers it is
pretty scary to say the least
before we get started my friends go to
timcast.com become a member help support
our work as a member you will get access
to our uncensored shows we're gonna have
that tim cast uncensored after show
should be a lot of fun
and also
if you would like to help me lure people
into my right wing world
click the link in the description below
and purchase only ever wanted for 69
cents on bandcamp from uh from us over
here at tim cash we produce a song and
the daily beast says we're trying to
lure you into our right wing world okay
then tell your friends help us all lure
people over to the dark side uh that's
that's at least how they see it but if
you do want to support our work we got
more songs that are coming out you can
pick that up today is the last day
for the week of tracking for the release
and we didn't do any of that pre-order
stuff we we probably could have pushed
really really hard and done a big plan
for it but today's the last day so it's
your it's you'll always be able to get
the song whenever you want but today's
the day that really really matters so
click the link 69 cents we could use
your support would really appreciate it
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us to listen to joe biden's
mumbling yes is robert davie
thank you for having me tim it's great
to be here i'm excited about this i'm
curious to see the speech the propaganda
speech from the white house tonight
and uh being able to comment on it
because it's so frustrating to watch it
alone at home yes and and yell at the
television set now we can share this
moment of propaganda together you you uh
made a movie called my son hunter yes
which is out soon i believe correct yes
uh september 7th
you can go to miceonhunter.com you can
pre-order it now september 7th through
breibart you can get my son hunter the
film starring lawrence fox gina carrana
john james
newcomer called emma goyovic and it's a
terrific film it's uh as if the laptop
exploded onto the screen oh gosh so
for those i think many people know who
you are but you're i mean you're a big
movie star you've been in all the you've
been you're the best bond villain you're
in goonies
kill license die hard stargate atlanta's
show girls
some people like show cops
about 160 films biden's getting ready to
come out so we'll try and go quick we
also have alex marlow
yes editor-in-chief of breitbart news
and we're the distributors of the film
tim it's really great to be on with you
and i really really appreciate a lot of
what you're doing in the culture not
just with the show but with the music
and it's very cool to be here biden's
coming we got lauren southern she's
drinking here we go again we haven't
been trying to stop
yes the bingo now how do we how do we
work with these bingo cards is it too
late we had charlottesville i don't see
it here
okay real quick real quick lydia's here
as well because biden's getting ready to
speak i am i'm here let's go all right
let's uh let's let's
there we go here we go
[Music]
all right so we have bingo cards
um
and we're going to be checking off
because we did last time and actually
lauren's the only one drinking
unbelievable i love inappropriate
contact on here yes i have
soul of the nation oh gosh yeah i think
that's like the name of the speech
it is do i get that one already i think
so yeah that counts but he's he's
repeating that he did that the first
time around oh here he goes here he
comes you ready
i'm scared
my fellow americans oh no he already
can't talk to me
wait is coughing on here was that max
should be i speak to you tonight
from sacred ground in america
independence hall in philadelphia
pennsylvania
this is where america made its
declaration of independence to the world
more than two centuries ago
with an idea
whoa unique
among nations holy cow he's three
minutes late starts late
do it create it equal
this is where the united states
constitution was written
and debated
this is where we set in motion
the most
extraordinary experiment of
self-government
the world has ever known which are
taking away from us with three simple
words
no irony we the people
we the people
these two documents
and the ideas they embody
equality and democracy are the rock upon
which
this nation is built
they are how we became
the greatest nation on earth
they are why
for more than two centuries
america has been a beacon to the world
yeah yeah yeah come on come on
but as i stand here tonight
equality and democracy
are under assault
by your administration
to pretend otherwise americans don't
like you so tonight
i've come to this place where it all
began
to speak as plainly as i can but you
haven't seen the nation
yeah come on guys about the threats we
face
the threats we have about the power we
have in our own hands i hear the liberty
about the incredible future
the lies in front of us
if only
we choose it
we must never forget
we the people
are the true heirs of the american
experiment okay what is he doing that
began more than two centuries ago
he's historically waiting for the people
the propaganda is the good part
our way through abolition when you're
blowing out
you know get everybody excited about
that
i'm the real patriot yeah
free and just
that is the work of my presidency this
is cultural appropriation of real
america i believe now
my whole soul
oh soul first yes ah come on you must be
honest with each other
what with ourselves
[Laughter]
is that something that's happening in
our country today oh wait what's this
not
normal
yes it's you people donald trump and
they said republicans
extremism
that threatens the very foundations
trump is falling higher than biden right
now i want to be very clear
very clear up front
i wonder if they had an employee not
even the majority of the republicans or
republicans
mega republicans not every republican
embraces their extreme ideology they
should yes like liz cheney or lynn
cheney because i've been able to work
with these mainstream republicans
mainstream but there's no question he
means rhinos the republican party today
is dominated driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
this is crazy stuff
these are hard things this is very
frightening seriously but i'm an
american civil war level rhetoric from
the president yeah
president of red america blue america
what do you mean red america blue
america are you going to give that
speech that obama
is my baby my duty to level with you to
tell the truth no matter how difficult
well then talk about your son's laptop
oh my gosh
and here in my view is what is true
republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they did not recognize the will of the
people hey will the people i would
refuse to accept the results of a free
election
they're working right now
as i speak in state after state
to give power
to decide elections in america to
partisans and cronies
empowering election denials this is what
you've been doing
this is the president using the white
house to campaign to deliver a campaign
speech to take this country backwards
what what is that law that he's
violating
there is some law i don't know what it
is there's uh where there is no right to
choose campaign i'll look at it now
they're doing this using the government
to campaign you guys change the
elections
of political violence
that are a threat
what did christine uh what's her name
maxine waters say justice what did
schumer say
what are you talking about the very soul
of what they look at the mob the storm
the united states capital on january 6th
january 6th brutally attacking law
enforcement i have that one not as
insurrectionist oh
but they're looking as patriots
and they see their magnificent stop a
peaceful transfer of power yeah yeah
after the 2020 election saying trump
didn't as preparation for the 2022 and
2024 elections is that protesters
they're tried yeah everything's last
time it sounds like it's just to nullify
the votes of 81 million people
this time
they're determined to succeed in
thwarting the will of the people you
know
listen that's why joey respected
conservatives joey
i got to tell you something
tell him michael
has called
trump and the extreme maga republicans
quote a clear
and present danger to our democracy
but while the threat to american
democracy is real
i want to say as clearly as we can
we are not powerless
in the face of these threats
we are not bystanders in this ongoing
attack on democracy
there are far more americans
far more americans
from every from every background of
belief
who reject the extreme mag ideology he's
not just those that accept people who
are on january 6th anymore he's saying
the democratic party is a marxist
cultural revolution that you're
determined to shut up
you're the one that's trying to come
after shaping everything you guys have
changed the election laws
you guys must choose what's doing what
fascism is to move forward robert how
old are you move backwards you want the
truth yeah to build a future obsession
have you ever heard a president give a
speech like it's a nation of hope and
unity and optimism i haven't heard
the democratic party do this i haven't
visited politicians darkness
i've had republicans
they thrive on chaos
they live not in the light of truth but
in the shadow of lies
what are you talking about
lies joe
we can choose a better path joe whiz
corn pop the guy the guy who claims he
drives an 18-wheeler future a
possibility
build and dream and hope no joke joe
and we're on that who wrote the speech
joe
i know this nation
i know you the american people
i know your courage
i know your hearts
and i know our history
this is you flip-flop during history joe
we do not reject it
this is a nation that believes in the
rule of law
we do not report what happened for two
years as the riots were happening what
happened to law
where did you respect the police
officers you guys didn't say anything
joe we do not deny it
and this is a nation
that rejects violence as a political
tool that's what you did with antifa
and blm
how could you lie like this
tell us the truth and then we can
respect you liberty justice for all hope
possibilities we are still at our core a
democracy
and yet we're a republic of
constitutional republic yeah
constitutional republican history tells
us that's awkward
the blind loyalty to a single leader
and a willingness to engage in political
violence is fatal to democracy
for a long time
we've told ourselves that american
democracy is guaranteed he's saying a
lot of enough but it's not he is
probably defended
period protected not good at it
is
74 million voters
this is
you know and he's riling up i would have
told if i would have said four years ago
front extremists president 2022 would
give a speech calling half the nation
democrats independents mainstream
republicans
we must be stronger more determined and
more committed to saving america this is
the type of stuff they used to do behind
closed doors this is the basket of the
deplorables comment but as a 20-minute
prime time speech we the people the
quiet part is that the plan 20 minutes
anyone well
because i can't stand it
it feels like an abusive relationship
around us you know we also have to watch
mccarthy's recording
oh we're here oh yeah let's because we
could criticize that if they don't
violence
he's going to do nothing
i hope
in this country
see it's only violence if it's not
doing it if
for political violence in america period
then why are you doing it forever the
looting and the antifa our inner cities
have violence
what are you doing defunding the police
what about to defund the police what
about fentanyl the violence that's
pouring in because of the border journal
this isn't even true we've seen election
officials poll workers many of them
volunteers both killed subjects
they were attacked
but
can you believe it
fbi agents oh fbi oh just doing their
job as directed facing traits
what about the supreme court justices
joe from their own supreme court
justices joe on top of that aren't they
citizens public figures today yesterday
and the day before predicting and all
but calling
for mass violence and rioting from
maxine waters and for schumer when we
had a decision
it's dangerous it's against the rule of
law
and we the people must say
this is not who we are it's their
democracy it's not ours
how many times has he talked about
violence
we can't allow violence to be normalized
in this country it's wrong but you did
that with that it could be
black lives matter john
with all the morals there were no maga
people rioting the streets joe for two
years
we can't let them they were sick of
having three years of what happened in
america and the government did nothing
so they went to the capitol
to protest
what they saw was that destruction of
our constitution and the democracy yeah
we'll never i believe in the give and
take of politics in disagreement and
debate and dissent no you don't none big
complicated seriously when they spend
yeah but democracy endures
only if
we the people respect the guard rails of
the republic only if
we the people accept the results of free
and fair elections who cares there's
crime happening
in america that he's not addressing
politics
it's basically that is trump shot
differently how do you think they've got
the captions
or they were cheated
and that's where the maga republicans
are today he's acting like none of us
existed between 2016 and 2020 where they
don't understand our votes in 2016
patriotic america knows
that for three years of your country
and pelosi
had russian collusion that was a false
fbi
government
um
attack on the presidency of the united
states
[Music]
we respect our legitimate political
differences
i will not stand by and watch
a 15-minute speech this year will be
overturned wild conspiracy theories and
baseless evidence-free claims of fraud i
will not stand by and watch elections in
this country stolen by people who simply
refuse to accept they go
the projection the project they've been
doing it since kennedy when kennedy was
losing they went to sam giancana
and they said we need votes in this
country and that's how they beat nixon
and have your vote counted
and be taken from you and the american
people
look
as your president i will defend our
democracy with every fiber of my being
and i'm asking every american to join me
he keeps repeating this
it's so strange and you know they say
trump is the one who's obsessed with the
election obsessed with you know
america's often made the greatest
progress they're just as obsessed coming
out of some of our darkest moments like
you're here we're the protesters
i believe we can and must do that again
there's some fjb channels we are we're
there yeah i'm funny mega republicans
look at america and see carnage and
darkness and despair
i've been on the streets
well go to los angeles
walk around with your nice sunglasses
and see if somebody comes and rips them
off
an america with an unlimited future
on america that's about to take off
i hope you see it as well just look
around
aside from it being like i have no idea
this amazing economy my friends
loving the economy everyone
so we passed the biggest infrastructure
investment since president dwight d
eisenhower and we've now embarked on a
decade of rebuilding the nation's roads
bridges highways ports water systems
high-speed internet railroads
[Applause]
i believe we could make america safer so
we passed the most significant gun
safety laws says president clinton
i believe
i believe that the district attorneys in
major cities are letting criminals out
how are we safer the world to making
prescriptions drugs and health care more
affordable so we passed the most
significant health care reform since
president obama
affordable care act
[Applause]
and i believe we create
we could create a clean
energy future and save the planet
so we passed the most important climate
initiative ever ever ever and we'll go
back to your cars between four and seven
exactly don't water your lawn and we'll
be using candles in a few years
tell us nothing can get done
but they're wrong
there is not a single thing america
cannot do not a single thing beyond our
capacity he's just campaigning
i hope america can vote you out of
office is what i hope but we're proving
that america no matter how long it's
looking good already
that's why he's doing this they're
afraid they're desperate you think so
absolutely you look at the maga
republicans who are winning and that's
what they're scared of the establishment
i know the last year a few years have
been tough i hope so to do but today i
think so covert no longer controls our
lives
more americans are working than ever
covet never control businesses are
growing our schools are open
millions of americans have been lifted
out of poverty let's go brand-new
well now get what they deserve for their
families in the comparison compensation
american manufacturers come alive across
the heartland
we want to root for people but when
you're you're demonizing like hillary
clinton with basketball deplorables when
you're demonizing better the american
people that are good people and that bet
is paying off i've looked them in the
eyes across this country that have a
different ideology than the marxist left
gun violence oh charlottesville we can't
see the light on here though huh light
is now visible that's how i know he's
coming
forward
not only in words but in actions actions
for you for your children for your
grandchildren people are screaming for
like ten straight even in this moment
can't do any inflections
yeah it's pretty good yeah i give you my
words now i've never
not because it may be because of who you
are but he was always like this we're
going to end the cancer as we know it's
my words
well there is a drug now there is a drug
that has
[Music]
man we're falling behind tell them
you're
i believe america is big enough for all
of us to succeed thank you and that is
the nation we're building a nation where
no one is left behind what about the
magazines i ran for president because
i still believe that to be true
i believe the soul
is the breath
the light people are and the essence of
who we are
the soul do maggots have souls it's us
us probably not the soul of america what
about the 50 million babies by the
sacred proposition that all are created
in the image of god why are megas
created equal all are entitled to be
treated with
decency they all deserve
justice and a shot at lives of
prosperity and consequences aside from
the maggots and that democracy democracy
must be defended for democracy makes all
these things possible no it doesn't
folks what country is he talking about
a democratic one
what's up josh he's talking about
venezuela democracy begins and will be
preserved
and we the people's habits of the heart
in our character what about the
immigration optimism that is tested yet
endures
courage that digs deep
when we need it
empathy that fuels democracy the
willingness to see each other not as
enemies but as fellow americans you just
made everybody enemies joe went home
he's gonna say democracy perfect more
democracy is bad
i'm trying to hear this standing those
folks you hear on the other side there
they're entitled to be outrageous how
unifying this is democracy
then why are you trying to silence
good manners is nothing they've ever
suffered from
but history and common sense tell us
that opportunity liberty and justice for
all
are most likely to come to pass in a
democracy
we have never fully realized the
aspirations i hope he says democracy
again later but every generation has
opened those doors a little bit wider
to include more people who have been
excluded before
that's right
americans
it beats in all our hearts it unites
america
it is the american creed
republic the idea that america
guarantees that everyone be treated with
dignity
it gives hate no safe harbor
it installs in everyone the belief that
no matter where you start in life
there's nothing you can't achieve
that's who we are
that's what we stand for
that's what we believe
and that's precisely what we're doing
opening doors
creating possibilities
focusing on the future
and we're only just beginning
no that was me
close enough hello he's just talking
about we can never
a guy who's been in washington for 50
years he's only just beginning
people are chatting that he's trying to
start a civil war
that's what it sounds and this work is
the work of democracy
the work of this generation
is the work of our time for all time
we can't afford to leave anyone outside
sirens we need everyone to do their part
so speak up are you going to have
internment camps what's going to happen
yeah please vote if we do our duty
if we do our duty
2022 and beyond
that age is still to come we'll say we
all of us here we kept the faith we
preserve democracy
he's not needed our word he's not the
guy right not the guy
our worst
no it's flat
obama was good that's why he's yeah
the
finally 20 minutes in nothing more
american is that whispering that's ours
oh he did it that's who we truly are
yeah
that's almost we must always be
do you think oh yeah that's what he's
saying
he's been a politician too long i don't
think so this is who we will be is he
what you said everybody would come
together as a nation not much i don't
think he knows you've ever heard his
speech over the last 40 years that for
the next 200 years
watch him speak and go flip flop
flip-flop great but he's also at this
stage lost his mind
states of america the united states of
america old man why are you splitting us
apart
and may god protect all those who stand
watch over our democracy god bless you
all walk the wrong way dude go the wrong
way please i want to win this
go the wrong way if he high-fives the
air you know he thinks he's got it
they're not going to watch him
wait
come on come on is that it where's he
going
inappropriate contact yes now he's
[Music]
his handler there to take him on stage
the right direction wait he tried
talking it didn't work
[Music]
smart did anybody win
who won no
i think you got the closest i needed him
to go the wrong way if he walked the
wrong way i had soul the nation trump
starts late and the free space
if if he went the wrong way i would have
got it ah boo
yeah
i feel like everything he said tonight
was with the caveat except for those
darn maga republicans that's pretty much
it is that he says we're the greatest
nation on the earth aside from all the
racist horrible mega people half the
country and we need to unify aside from
all those horrible racist people it's
not unified with them of course so he's
allowed to do this i i that the hatch
act actually allows the president the
vice president to campaign oh really
yeah
it just it i just i'm not entirely sure
that he can use the government apparatus
to do it like the official white house
channel to do a campaign speech which is
what he did
this is uh
look man i've been talking about civil
war
for going on like five years now yes and
people called me crazy he said tim's
nuts it's never gonna happen and i i
tried explaining to people that what you
see on the ground level with people who
are fighting in the streets is trickling
upwards the culture war is reaching its
way into every branch of government and
it will reach the highest levels this is
what we're seeing now when the president
literally comes out and says something
even more extreme than trump said
you know i mean and trump comes out and
he's you know he smack talks democrats
but smacking democrats that's that's
politics right joe biden dedicated a
speech
prime time
to condemn 74 million voters incredible
that's crazy yeah don't misread that's
exactly what he's doing and this is a
guy who campaigned promising unity he
can't get one republican to support any
one of his pieces of legislation and he
comes out and he acts like we're
supposed to just blindly follow his
vision only his vision and if we differ
at all we're now bad people and we need
to be condemned why wasn't he has he
ever given a speech like this about
china or about iran or about one of the
actual threats to this country or is it
is it just us the people in this room
can i just say something
i don't think we should paint them as
crazy
i think we should as a threat to our
republic
because it's orchestrated it's marxist
uh rhetoric
it's uh on purpose
there are people behind this that have
been there for decades the globalists
the klaus schwabs of the world
uh
so by amy just he's crazy no we've got
to come up with a better strategy
to get the message out and combat this
on the other side on our side joe biden
when he was running they said
stay alive joe biden we just need your
corporeal form that was an actual
article that was written
they were they were running against
trump yes now they're in a very
difficult position because biden is he
is anything but charismatic and so this
is their big push because the midterms
coming up and they desperately need
something but they know they're losing
this it's a scary speech but i gotta be
honest it makes me laugh because they're
they're terrified it's it's that scene
from starship troopers when doogie
hauser puts his hand on the thing and
then turns around yells it's afraid and
goes
like that's exactly what this is
he had to say maga republicans in
democracy 50 times because they're
losing
i feel like um they also just have
nothing to grasp on to except january 6.
like this sounded like it should have
been a law and order speech right he's
constantly talking about we need to have
peaceful americans this that but
forget about the fentanyl deaths forget
about the murders the asian hate crimes
going on the border all of that nah the
democrats really care about a bit of
trespassing by grandma on january 6.
that's the law and order of the
democrats because that's all they have
because all the other crime going on is
their fault it's their cities let me let
me pull up this uh story we got here
from greg price the biden administration
asked meta if they would take down a
fouchy parody account on instagram
this
the white house emailed meta saying hi
hi there any way we can get this pulled
down it's not actually one of ours
it was a fouchy parody account they were
trying to get banned because the white
house is actively participating in the
censorship and facebook is taking
instruction from them that's right at
this point we need
anybody who shared the hunter biden
laptop story and was suppressed or
anybody who shared it in general because
mark zuckerberg admitted to suppressing
it
to file a first amendment suit against
facebook and the government because they
colluded to violate your free speech
you know rudy giuliani had a meeting
with him on this film on his show
and he told me that when they
got his uh they went to get his stuff
right they fbi came in and took his
stuff
and he said to them he says well well
you want these and there were two
laptops and they said what are those he
goes there's a hunter biden's laptop
and
fbi said oh no no no we don't want those
we're good on that we're good on that i
mean figure that out i mean so the
suppression of it and and uh
it's it's uh
we're at a very dangerous time i have
not seen this in my lifetime and we've
had it just brings up it just brings up
what this unbelievable story with
zuckerberg admitting flat out the fbi
came to him asked him to suppress stuff
maybe it was the 100 laptop maybe they
already knew about it but whatever it
was and zuckerberg sends a signal that
i'm i'm game let's play ball and we
reached out to the fbi breitbart and
they didn't reply which we can read into
that what exactly what you think and so
now it's game on so now the government
knows they can just go to all these
social media giants all these tech
giants and just say will you please do
this for me and they've every reason to
believe the answer's gonna be yes every
time they should because they want those
protections they want those
it's good business for them to do what
the buying administration says and
that's the essence of the speech it's
sort of a dictatorial speech it's sort
of if you disagree with me you were the
bad guy you were the problem not just
with the country but with planet earth
he's never singled out an enemy like
this other than the regular trump voters
that is his ultimate enemy it's a
fascist
uh speech
it is a thing that if you ever watch the
movie
yeah i don't want to say it but
absolutely
1930s germany now you got to realize
something if you watch the movie dr
zhivago
and everyone thinks of it as it's a it's
a film that uh
uh
who's the great director stanley kubrick
and
everyone thinks of it as a love story
between julie christie and omar sharif
it's exactly what's happening in america
today my wife comes from estonia that
part of the world oh nice yeah and she
i want i showed her the movie the other
day
they experienced what's happening today
she's terrified the signs are out there
of what happened in that and i if you
get a chance watch dr zhivago even in
terms of
the taking away our weapons and then
taking away our land
but you know they're not powerful enough
it the signs are there we're seeing um
history rhyme
but
they're moving
too quickly i mean look we are a
massively armed population they would
certainly like that to not be the case
but it is the case yes and so i kind of
you know
the reason why i've long said civil war
is because
in my mind the path we're going leads to
a president denouncing half the country
but the other half of the country is
able to muster up defense and an economy
and some kind of system to survive and
persist
there's a possibility that it could be
wrong in that it's not going to be a
civil war it's going to be a revolution
in which case that is biden wins without
a fight that people just say okay well
whatever and then the fbi starts
arresting people starts raiding people
he starts silencing people and they've
been making tremendous inroads in that
in that way arrests you know going after
the former president unprecedented what
we are seeing right now is coup level
revolutionary level they sent the fbi to
the home of donald trump to take
documents he had the authority to
declassify this has never happened
before
this is one administration weaponizing
law enforcement to target his political
rivals and they claimed trump was doing
it trump tried investigating the
corruption of the biden family in the
ukraine do you remember when trump
that's right when trump wanted to do a
big parade with flyovers and show off
some of the equipment for fourth of july
yeah okay what did biden just do he just
put the put the military right behind
him to intimidate the maggots that we
will come get you he's already said he's
he's already shown he'll throw the fbi
the former president he's doing this
classic projection he's doing all the
stuff we've been accused of doing for
hopefully they've done this for decades
wow this is their agit prop this is
their marxist cultural revolution this
is an escalation this is a massive
escalation i i that's the reason i asked
your age is because we had someone super
chat saying i'm 60 and i've never seen
anything like this before right i i i
try to ask you know older people all the
time when i see him like have you ever
felt it this way or this bad the answer
is no i talked to a guy in an antique
store and i asked him about you know
because he was in his 60s and i asked
him about the weather underground he's
like oh yeah i remember all that stuff
and then i was like is it worse today
and he's like well that stuff was bad
but the entirety of today feels way
worse all right talk about bilayers and
the weather underground on their website
back in the day on their constitution
now the weather underground
they said they wanted to get a white
liberal fighting force combine it with
the black liberation movement
to bring down america imperialism
colonialism and institute world
communism that's bill ayers and bernard
adorne this is what was on their website
obama i think right yes absolutely now
the people see we're not telling this
this is what's wrong with the gop
they've got to talk about this we've got
to give historical reference point to
what happened now you've got da's
financed by george soros and you've got
them
chase chase bodine was raised by bill
ayers and bernadette thorne because his
parents this is the d.a in san francisco
who's letting criminals out and the same
guy gets going in new york saying uh in
l.a this is a absolute orchestrated
infiltrated thing bill ayers went more
underground and what he started to do
was infect education and the textbooks
this is what they did and meanwhile our
education i read a book when i was a kid
i recommend it
called my dad was a knight of columbus
he gave me a book this is in the late
1950s early 60s none dare call it
treason by john stormer who was
considered a
a john birch society guy and they tried
to minimalize that
none there called the treason and
masters of the seat was another book by
j edgar hoover
he said read these books you never
talked politics a lot i read these books
and i've seen this incremental it
started with taking prayer out of school
no more pledge of allegiance
infiltrating education it gave the
playbook of what the left was their play
before saul alinsky and before that they
knew this
and we've let it happen our politicians
have made deals you've got mitch
mcconnell
who has deals with all over the place
these guys i mean they go into politics
and they get wealthy they're not
worrying about the american people this
is now that's why i say you need a
george washington because in a way
you need somebody that's going to exp
and trump was strong enough to expose a
lot of this and get the ball rolling on
it and he got
you know what what about ronnie sanders
what do you think about ronnie i love
ronda sanders he's just an amazing
person he
yeah he i live in florida now oh nice
and he's taking on yeah i moved after 45
years of being in los angeles i couldn't
take what was happening so you know
donald trump
wanted to drain the swamp he wanted to
fire these bureaucratic state
individuals he made a lot of mistakes he
brought in some bad people and he
thought that he really would you know he
didn't realize the level of obstruction
with the russiagate stuff
so i'm wondering though
tactfully trump is is lacking right and
you know even even his ardent supporters
love that he talks and he's gruff and
and you know ron desantis has the
decorum and the the maga you know behind
him but he doesn't have the foreign
policy i wonder well here's the here's
my thinking and i bring this up to
people
i have got eight kids
say you had a child who's four years old
god forbid and he's very deathly ill and
you have somebody that
a doctor
who speaks right who does everything
wonderful will hold your hand while this
child is sick in the hospital the child
expires he'll come to the the cemetery
give you give you something and and call
up and how you doing that's that doctor
you got another guy that you maybe don't
want to spend an afternoon with he's
belligerent he's
you know
difficult to talk to he's a little bit
crass
but yet he's guaranteed to save your
child
now i i think you you need the
disrupting aspect of trump
and then desantis comes in for eight
years and rebuilds it but to answer your
question he was on the house for an
affairs committee and he was in fallujah
so i i i i i i don't think that's that
that would be the issue i think okay
yeah yeah yeah so yeah so do you think
desantis would you you think trump over
desantis would you agree trump over to
santa's like trump president vp desantis
then desantis president that would be
nice that would be interesting it's very
nice but is it wishful thinking yes
absolutely probably i'm i'm soundly in
the we should have a primary camp and if
trump decides he's going to run and he
tells everyone to clear out i'm afraid
we won't and i think a primary is better
i think it'll sharpen trump assuming
he's the front-runner
or perhaps we see something interesting
happen and i'm just afraid we're not
going to get the flesh out not just the
ideas but what you're talking about the
tactics the and this is something where
i think it's essential that we do this
and i don't know if it's happening right
now somebody which got a super chat
someone mentioned carl benjamin had a
great video called that has to be trump
and one of the points he makes is that
trump has to finish out his narrative
arc what he's what he started
good point i mean i mean look i've seen
and i love desantis i want him to stay
in florida for another four years but
i've seen him take
it's like him giving a trump message in
a certain way
yeah he does do that so trump has
ignited a thing and they've demonized
this guy so much now look at i don't
know all the ins and outs i don't know
um you know but i do know coming from
new york
i was born in new york i spent you know
26 years in new york okay coming from
new york i know you know you got oprah
you got people that he was revered by
he got the naacp award right people said
on both sides he helped clean the he
helped save he helped save the city yeah
with giuliani he understood that he he
did you know he understood go ahead i
was going to say he uh i watched a
documentary from a while back talking
about how trump
new york was dying nobody wanted to live
there wealthy people were fleeing and
then trump tower and his property
started bringing back the cool factor
and people all of a sudden now wanted to
be there
and that helped kick it in the butt
along with giuliani of course cleaning
up crime absolutely all these things his
central park ice skating rink is an
amazing story how he got that done i
mean by the by the skin of his teeth
it's super cool just to make new york a
happening place and but they turned on
him so hard because he had the wrong
politics and he disrupted the status quo
do you know about the woman
no but i don't think it was people
should know about the warming rink
tell me what happened because the
warming rink was an ice skating rink
and this is why it's so important when
he says i just gave a three trillion
dollar infrastructure bill okay we know
what that's going to go to we know the
waste of money and this story says the
waste of government and i've written
about this walman rink talked about it
because i was there the woman rink was
something that in the 1950s the woman
family gave 650 000 to do an ice rink in
new york
mayor koch and the city parks department
wanted to
rev
renovate it so they put in
two years and three million dollars
to renovate this
ice rink
and
a little girl is watching from
her house daddy when is the rink gonna
be ready this is three years she goes
well honey they should have it soon
uh
four years and six million dollars six
years and nine million dollars and
donald trump says what the hell is going
on here so he goes into the fray and new
york city there was a big political
upheaval about it and he got the rink he
got the rink
and they said that
any overages he would pay for himself
any underages he would give to the
cerebral palsy the homeless and aids
victims this is in the 80s and the
papers were fighting him and everything
else he got the rink
he did it in less than four months
and the first thing he said is like he
does
all right he said who designed this rink
and they said well we've got this
florida guy that's a refrigeration
expert and the trump common sense goes
what the heck does he know about
refrigeration so what he does is he says
he calls up the montreal canadiens and
says who builds your ring so and so now
here's what happens and i've seen this
when we build highways it takes an
inordinate long time why
well in the ice rink
they went down and the guy said uh they
were putting down copper tubing right
because they have to put down copper
tubing
and then they have to fill it up with
the uh freon and then put it the cement
and then the water and all of that well
the copper tubing
was being ripped off
over the years
so who was getting that and then more
was putting down this is nine years oh
my okay so so now what happens is trump
gets this guy and then they put freon in
it they pour the cement the cement on
one side is this high it's that low on
the other side they never tested if
there were any holes in the
but
they had holes in it and they so the guy
says to trump he says mr trump they
don't use copper tubing for ice rings
you use rubber tubing you don't use
freon you use a former brine
he saved 750 000
gave it to the homeless this is our
government
and this is when they talk about
infrastructure that's why one of the
reasons why i said okay i want this guy
in and even oprah do you remember the
oprah interview with him did you ever
see it
put it up during his uh
19 no 25 years ago oh yeah yeah you saw
that yeah yeah he talked about the same
thing
this guy has talked about the same thing
in terms of getting ripped off at that
time japan china nato countries not
paying their fair pay he was always
america first he was not a globalist
and they've painted him they've
assassinated this man so that's where my
frustration is because
they've made it so so uh uh what i was
gonna say is uh
it's not his politics it's sort of you
know his policies i don't think matter
all that much what matters is that he
i should say his domestic policy matters
very little compared to his
international policy
ending the wars
no new wars bringing our troops back
they don't like
that when he comes into office they say
you know the intelligence agencies will
come to him and say here's what you're
going to do now here's here's our plan
and he goes no and they go excuse us
and so they go to war with him russia
gate it's endless now the fbi raiding
his home because they said we're in
charge and you'll you'll do what we want
and trump said no
i lived in washington in the beltway for
about eight nine years and one of the
biggest shocks while i was there was
realizing the military-industrial
complex is not a conspiracy theory it's
100 real and these people are not going
to vote for people or appoint people who
are going to take away from their their
bottom line they are not going to have
policies that are going to reduce their
income level and the responsible
policies the way you do modern warfare
right now we do not need to have the
military-industrial complex that's the
scale we do the only politician in
america who really understood that
apparently was trump and he comes in
maybe there's a couple others but not
none with his platform he comes in this
is a huge threat and he had a very
minimalist foreign policy piece through
strength it was entirely effective and
this is something that is a huge threat
because that is how they make all their
money look at where all these guys go
when they're out of the administration
they go into this loop this revolving
door they make millions of dollars in
contracting and then back into the
government for the next establishment
establishmentarian administration look
at what they did in afghanistan the
billions of dollars that was left there
the planes the weaponry the the the the
i mean how could they how could you do
that
how is it intentional right of course
surrendered
absolutely if ian were here but ian's
off for the night he would he would tell
you that biden surrendered our forces
and and he's correct biden abandoned
bagram air force base without telling
our partners in afghanistan that makes
no sense there's no way you do that on
accident such a scandal yeah and then it
was looted by rape by by just random
people and then we drowned a bunch of
kids right after yeah yeah good stuff
and it doesn't talk about and joe wants
to give a nice little speech on that let
me jump to the story from the new york
times
trump's lawyers may become witnesses or
targets in documents investigation and
then we have this
lawyer representing oath keepers
arrested over january 6 from timcast.com
they're going after the legal
representation of people
but this is this is look guys
the president just gave a speech
where he said half the country are
an existential threat to our democracy
karine jean-pierre said this word
extreme the mag republicans are an
extreme threat to this country and
democracy and double down on this
calling them semi-fascist or fascist or
whatever and now they're arresting the
legal representation or at least
targeting the legal representation
this is unprecedented level of look
call it civil war or call it pre-civil
war
but what we saw in the first civil war i
call it the first civil war it's kind of
funny right what we saw in the civil war
in the 1860s was abraham lincoln
suspending habeas corpus in a corridor
stretching from dc up to uh up to
pennsylvania through maryland and they
randomly arrested people they didn't
like in that corridor and they arrested
around 30 or so members of the maryland
legislature because they were
sympathetic to the south
when war is happening
your rights are gone
what we're seeing now you can call it uh
some people have chatted saying that was
a pre-war speech
that's something you hear i said
hitler-esque yeah i know god wins law
everything devolves i do not see nazi
germany or whatever but a president
coming out and giving a fiery angry
speech condemning half the country and
saying we have to fight against them is
insane
but then when the federal government
goes after the lawyers of people it's
well beyond that it's one thing to come
out and be like donald trump did a bad
thing and we're going to prove it and
it's like i don't believe you
but you know we still have to abide by
this process until we either vote these
people out fire them or get some
accountability but show me the evidence
we did that with russiagate i very much
was like okay show me the evidence prove
it turns out it was a hoax it was all a
lie a manipulation to jam up trump now
they're going after the lawyers
this is that's it
when they go for the lawyers they're
basically saying there's no laws there's
no rules and there's nothing you can do
about it and people need to understand
how real this is like every lawyer that
took these cases for the oath keepers
for trump everything they actually would
have known the risk involved and they
would have been having conversations
with their friends and family people at
their law firm saying you know what
could happen to you right because you
know everyone walking around day to day
they kind of think the system's
functioning properly people get treated
fairly but when you're in it you see it
you know that you're gonna get screwed
over last time i came here on tim cast
um the guy who checked me in for my
immigration
he freaked out when he looked at the
screen because i was pulled into the
back room for questioning as usual and
he started passing me notes private what
do you mean uh immigration on my way in
from canada to come do this show okay
and the private notes he passed me said
that you've been put on a watch list
basically where you're gonna be pulled
in for the rest of your life because of
some random agent in seattle i haven't
traveled to seattle in years who put you
on a list because you're associated with
people like stefan mall and you and he
put you on a flag list right that's the
kind of stuff that they know i get i get
held up for eight hours sometimes i'm
not able to make flights thousands of
dollars missed and that's just one of
the operations the things they do behind
the scenes to make sure
you know but you can do this this is a
perfect example to illustrate that and
what they're really doing is they're
toxifying anyone associated
professionally or as a high-level
volunteer with the any right of center
anti-establishment movement they're
making sure that trump can't staff a
government if he gets back in they're
making it so that we can't hire people
that's right so we we have conversations
periodically with high-profile creatives
and there's always an issue i i know a
lot of
musicians
professional athletes and they'll
message me and say things like i agree
with you the point of this is to make
them say dude i really i really can't
i'm sorry man i'll lose everything look
what they're doing look what they're
doing and
but you know what
some people are cowards
and that's that's that's the unfortunate
reality and if the issue is the people
who agree with freedom liberty
individual personal responsibility and
individualism if if if
if those of us if this faction is
dominated by cowards well then we
deserve to lose
that being said i think this shows we
are winning i'm not i'm not saying that
to get down i'm saying that if you look
at carrie lake's victory you look at liz
cheney losing
m the midterms are looking like it's
going to be good and that was joe biden
crapping his pants in fear knowing he's
about to get impeached because the
republicans are preparing an impeachment
on several friends i pray you're right i
i i pray you're right you know
people gotta register their make sure
they're gonna vote people have to vote
people just get they have to register
right now
you can go out to your neighbors and say
register to vote and maybe they won't
we've had a lot of people message saying
i went out and talked to 42 people two
people registered good enough yeah
that's what we got my fear is that the
roe versus wade thing
i don't believe it you know i don't
think so i don't think the roving white
stuff is going to be see see this is
what he's talking about there's a direct
quote from the speech backwards to in
america this is the the mod the maggots
are taking us backwards to an america
where there is no right to choose no
right to privacy if he's trashing us
because we don't think you should have a
limitless right to scramble a baby's
brain and vacuum it out like that that's
insane that's not even what happened the
supreme court just had the states
right of course
but most of the country knows this not
all of it but most of the country knows
that that's what happened this is this
is what desperation looks like going
after lawyers
if they were winning none of this would
be necessary right they have they they
it's a death rattle it's it's they
become more and more extreme the more
this is panic
you know people who are calm and
collected and know they're going to win
don't freak out and scratch at the walls
tim i got a question for you do you
think they've done the calculation what
happens
if the conversation ends if we can no
longer speak to one another obama lied
to us but he would at least try to
convince us he would try to bring us to
his side he's saying i don't want to
talk to you i want to shut you down i'm
going to stick the fbi on you i got 87
000 new irs agents i got the military
behind me he kind of looked like he was
in like a pit of hell like with a red
background what was that about well it
looked more like the vendetta moment
will happen yeah so but but do you think
do you think they get it that if we
can't talk it's gonna get much worse in
this country if we can't talk to one
another
look
in 2019
you know i'm talking to jack dorsey and
he mentioned on rogan's show sure
liberal journalists only follow liberal
journalists and conservatives follow
liberal and conservative journalists
that's right it has always been the case
that one side of the country was
brainwashed in the cult thinking they
weren't brainwashed in the cult and it
was everyone else
that's still true today absolutely bill
mayer's show with rob reiner
oh man but but even bill murray refused
no but i'm saying reiner
refused to admit that that the hunter
biden laptop was hidden right he refused
to admit it but bill maher's the one who
said if a recession stops trump then
bring on the recession now all of a
sudden he has the nerve to come out and
be like they shouldn't have hid the
laptop well i'll say this
respect for doing the right thing bill i
just wish he did the right thing in the
first place
i don't believe he was ignorant to what
was going on i think he was pandering
because he was saying what he thought
liberals wanted to hear now he realizes
the wokeness has gone insane and the
safe bet is in the moderate space tim
the number one rule in politics has
always been it's better to be wrong too
late than write too early yeah always
for these people well uh what's the
what's the saying
um
what is it it's something like uh
telling the truth is dangerous when the
government is wrong or something like
that you know you know that quote yeah i
i wonder if by the way that biden was
speaking in that speech was still as if
the maggies were a small minority of the
country right like they're that's what
it is he kept saying like oh we've got
all these republicans i don't care what
your opinions are as long as you're for
democracy and protecting the integrity
of this nation like i i wonder if he's
actually trying to gaslight people
or do they not realize we can look at
the voting numbers yeah i i want to we
can see how many people are maggies
i want to point out like
they're trying to peel them away i was i
was talking about uh mark ruffalo the
other day he's uh you know he plays the
hulk i'm sure uh you know and he gave
out an interview to variety and it was
actually one of the funniest things i've
ever read because
they asked him if you know something
like are you gonna play the hulk in the
future and he said maybe you know we'll
do old hulk because there's like old
hulk but he goes you know the way the
way things are headed and what we're
facing right now in this country there
might not be a world in which we can do
these things so i hope i'm still around
to do it and so he's kind of like saying
like the world may end as we know it so
i can't play the hulk anymore
and that was an intense thing because i
don't completely disagree with him to be
honest but the best part was the variety
interviewer goes ah okay moving on so
anyway and i'm like dude just told you
the world was ending he he does this all
the time he he'll tweet something
suggesting the world's ending and then
he'll have a head shot of himself with a
smoldering hot look just like
he's trying to seduce people with his
insane left wing rhetoric but well but
he's but it looks great content for us
so we're grateful i think people are
doing it yeah i mean look i i don't
agree with him i don't agree with him
politically yeah when he said we're
headed towards dark dark days or
whatever he's implying i think he's
right but my ultimately what i want to
get to is
you know
earlier today i'm skating i'm i'm trying
to i'm going by the half pipe or the
quarter pipe i'm getting bigger i'm
having a good time i'm skating and i'm
thinking you know like things are going
well the midterms are probably going to
be good we got the chickens life is good
i'm watching i'm watching um reading
stories about tv shows people are making
fun of she-hulk and i'm like that's kind
of normal like in the new she-hulk show
she's twerking and everyone's like
cringe
and then and and then and you get the
orange eggs like the orange yolk and the
eggs with the with the chickens well it
changes colors it's better than the
chicken i guess
that's so cool i'm super jealous yeah
well yeah it's it's good stuff sometimes
they're really dark and my point is it
was a good day today and then joe biden
comes out and he's like you're all evil
the world is ending and we're going to
destroy you and i'm like now i'm kind of
freaked out
you know like
look this is this speech like you said
i want somebody to take his speech in
the setting and put someone else's words
into it from
a certain period of our history the
1930s
and see how that matched up it would be
you know how they do these memes yeah
you've seen some of these shows that was
that look i know you're familiar with
it's godwin's law right is that what it
is you're familiar that all internet
arguments ultimately devolve to the
point of calling someone a nazi or
something like that
but to have a president come out right
right and say half the country man a
threat to our democracy it's just kind
of like yeah it's really crazy i think
robert made a good point earlier when he
said that he's trying to tear these
people away have you ever heard of
hungarian salami tactics that the
communists used where they would kind of
find little groups or fringes or protest
activism and then they'd publicly blast
them and make them so unacceptable to be
associated with that they'd cut them off
and then they'd slowly just do it to one
more group one more group one more group
until all of their opposition was
divided and right now they're trying so
hard to divide the mega republicans with
the regular republicans
and i mean they keep doing they they
applaud these other people that are
peeling away and those people bring
people with them and now mom and pop
that really don't know and are scared
about the economy and what's happening
to the world are sitting there going
you know
what do i do older older people
unfortunately they get their news from
the from the tv and the tv is lying to
them right so you know making sure that
we can spread the word among
well i mean it's it's it's it's there's
also the problem with the younger people
getting their news from just
cults you know what i mean in school
yeah yeah yeah so it's ultimately just
about finding where people get their
information and helping expose them this
is the thing that ronald reagan said the
most important thing and i wrote it on
breitbart the week trump won
i says
for his administration
ronald reagan the last speech he gave to
the american people
and the last part of that speech his
farewell speech was we need to have an
informed american patriotism the most
important thing he says we used to sit
around
the tv show and we would have shows
giving american values we would sit
around discussing things with american
values
he says and i fear and he saw the flag
getting this
he says i fear that unless we have a new
american patriotism where we're teaching
our children civics and the history of
america we're going to lose our nation
and this is what
i want i want to talk about solving the
problem here by pulling up this here
website
mysunhunter.com oh boy i want to start
by saying this first just for those that
aren't familiar this is a movie called
my son hunter and it's about the bidens
and i want to say
culture is everything politics is
downstream from culture
culture influences culture inspires
and cultures decide whether or not a law
truly stands on the books
for instance
there are old laws like you can't put a
pie on a window sill on tuesday because
it attracts wild animals and their
school kids out but no one enforces that
law
there's there's books called like wacky
laws and they're like did you know that
you can't no but really you can't take a
bath on sundays in massachusetts or
whatever
i want a copy of this book there's a
bunch of them actually they're funny and
those those laws are never repealed the
issue is our culture changed and we
decided okay we're not going to arrest
anybody for that anymore anymore i'm
pretty sure sodomy is still illegal in a
bunch of places as well no cop is going
to kick your door in because they think
two guys are hurting like we're not
doing that because culture but if we
were a theocratic fascist country they
would be kicking the door and saying
it's a law in the books right
building culture is the most important
thing we can do and that's why i think
the movie you guys are doing is is so
important do you want to explain what
the movie is who's in it what's it about
well it's my son hunter and it's based
on the
uh
not only the laptops and the information
the like peter schweitzer's book and
stuff that john solomon did and all the
articles uh at infinitum about the
hunter biden laptop it's also i i looked
at beautiful things
his autobiography to get a mindset of
him even though hunters hunt his book
oh no oh no i want him and he writes
about doing crack and all that you know
this is where robert differs from
hunters
uh robert actually read hunter's
biography
because we have all the
of course the the sizzle of
of of the corruption of the ukrainian
deals of the russian mafia deals of the
the chinese spy chief and the tons of
deals he made with the chinese flying uh
you got them to fly to china together on
air force two no i don't have that but
it's implied you'll see
in a different way and it's it's very
funny
i mean i should tell you i have joe with
a superman cape on for one second when
he when he visits the chinese and you
hear that
and hunter goes dad daddy
and now the deals start to happen but
uh
so it's all told through the eyes of a a
25 year old
uh left-wing activist who is a stripper
to pay for her college education
and she meets up with hunter a
relationships relationship
a bouncer from the strip joint is put
with them when they go to the chateau
marmot to have this big party
uh who's a
actor who is a soccer player of great
face franklin uh adelaide
a nigerian soccer player and he's the
one who says uh kitty i'm the black face
of white supremacy
and he's the one that navigates her
through the internet to find out when
she realizes this is joe biden's son my
life just got much more interesting i
wanna i wanna go back to the website
real quick so you uh so i was obviously
directed by robert dave you've got
lawrence fox john james gina carano and
emily uh godzikovic
there you go wow i totally butchered
that name who are you uh emma sorry emma
goevick uh so you got a bunch of great
people in here and uh you yourself for i
a lot of people already chatting they
know who you are they're they're
commenting on all the shows you've been
in they're like
they all recognize you from halo oh yeah
no no
that was just the voice
so i mean you're you're like you're a
big hollywood guy
and you're now
you know you you left you went to
florida now you're doing a movie that is
very much exposing the biden family i
have to imagine a lot of your old
friends are probably not happy
well you know if they're real friends
you know it's right you know look at i
have friends of mine that are absolutely
left-wing and it's what it is i say to
them okay i have lots of good friends
that are name actors that are
quiet conservatives that are frightened
about canceling and everything else in
their careers so there's a different
kind of a thing people that might have
uh
so
but um
we have to become culture warriors
yes as you said we have to we can't
worry about that because then we lay
them to do the narrative and we get left
out because the emotion of culture is
what
the young minds can respond to efforts
can move people have you watched the
show the boys no not yet i think it's
fantastic it is a little cringe have you
seen it alex i'm aware of it i haven't
seen it i don't even know about it aware
of it and i know all the memes nobody
nobody nobody has watched it uh so it's
basically
it's like the dc it's like dc's justice
league but if they're real people right
and so you end up with homelander right
he's like superman he's a narcissist
he's a sociopath he wants everyone to
love him
and then you know all of these
characters are basically flawed
celebrity types of superpowers and
that's kind of
the show explores and then there's
government cover-ups because the
superheroes accidentally kill people all
the time sure you know it's interesting
they've taken this turn in the show
where they've made superman into trump
they've made homelander basically trump
and this is the importance of culture in
the show
the good guys are like yo they're going
on tv and lying about what's going on
and there's like a fake tucker carlson
and then homelander clearly is lying
about things and then they say they're
they're clearly making him be trump then
they're saying he's lying and show you
fictional situations where he knows he's
lying too they're trying to to set your
preconceptions as to what's happening in
the world because they know there are
low information dumb people who are
going to see trump who go he he's lying
too oh i saw that on tv
and people might you know people who
watch the show might might give the
benefit of the doubt to the average
person but i'm telling you that level of
influence does work oh it does it does
and they'll think they're geniuses for
making that connection too
and so what you need like
here's what you do
you make a show that is not political
like the boys
but then you make a loser put a message
in the ravioli exactly put a message in
the ring
yes that's what i did with the film i've
got an important question and it has to
be a good ravioli and extremely tasty
cheese and spinach
mushroom you could have you could have a
vegetarian you can have ricotta mushroom
it has to be a beautiful sauce oh yeah
yeah
do you guys think uh hunter is going to
watch it
i think so because this is like again
the wolf of wall street and friends of
mine in hollywood you talked about some
of the hollywood friends you know conte
is like a counter culture hero yeah the
there was a drug abuse of the women and
the chateau malmo and guys used to say
you know i was at the chateau moment
when he was partying what a wild scene
that was let me tell you there's a read
on hunter that he's actually the only
cool democrat
so if you think about what he does
is totally unencumbered he's figured out
all these new grips think about the arc
let's take that oh my gosh he's so good
people send him tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands we don't know who
these people are his arts crap i mean
and robert does an incredible job
satirizing it in the movie but we don't
it's just an easy way to get none of us
thought of that none of us are that
smart because he's the one who's cutting
all the deals for that you've just blown
my mind maybe he realizes like my dad's
been bullshitting his whole life wait a
second joe was not lying when he said
hunter's the smartest guy he knows
he is serious this is this is the game
say he wasn't on crack you'll see it
you'll see in the film
about that we we this goes there in the
film
the girl figures it out
when she's having a conversation with
him that and and this is what makes it
again a very interesting uh film to me
well is that you can't
even when i was researching this a
a a actress friend of mine said you know
hunter
rented a uh airbnb from my friend
there was a laptop and another
there was a backpack and another laptop
there this guy was leaving stuff all
over the place
while he was getting high every 15
minutes dealing with the highest people
in china and everywhere else
so like cracked out of his mind and he's
like
his office here's my laptop the
supposition
the supposition tim is
are the laptops left on purpose yeah or
what and he hates his dad and he's just
like why can't i just lose him the
election already
this is uh yeah we don't go there but
we go there but you do have biden
sniffing children right
no no no no no he sniffs other people
there's a lot he says other people
i'll tell you what i think i think i
think uh joe biden is a pedophile and i
think he abused hunter
that
may or may not be i don't want to
watch the film please we'll check it out
the film that i don't want to go into
that because i didn't want to again i
wanted because
there are certain there's enough there
there's enough there enough red meat
there i wanted to make people that were
in the middle want to watch this film
because it's a good picture
while supplying the story and the truth
what we think allegedly happened let's
talk about corn pop oh yeah you know
what i think i think joe biden
besmirched the good name of queen
absolutely because if you listen to his
story what did he say the kids were
rubbing my legs do you remember this
he's like the kids are rubbing my legs
and the hair would curl and people have
commented someone super chatted
what if corn pop was a good guy who was
protecting the kids attacking the kids
from a creepy
i saw that i believe it i really do yeah
and joe's telling this nonsense story
about he called him esther or whatever
and the guy had a knife yeah i think he
like when he was in a rain barrel and it
was getting rusty and he bang it up
yeah
i think joe biden was at the pool with a
bunch of little kids being a creep and
corn pop was like yo
you need to get out of here and he was
like come on man
dude someone made a cartoon
where joe talks about the kids grabbing
his legs they animated it it's just so
much you've seen it oh yeah i love it
the kid's grabbing his legs what is this
guy yeah they're standing up they turn
blonde in the sun
he says this stuff out loud also in that
speech he called black children roaches
it was this he calls black children
roaches in the speech no one's caught
this it is the most racist comment i've
ever heard in my life period
this wasn't this wasn't 1969 this wasn't
1840. this was 2017. in what context he
said he was talking about the kids at
the pool he says i know how to deal with
roaches it's the craziest thing when you
play it back now you're going to freak
out it's unbelievable and he says in
this thing which is he
he is a he there's definitely a pervy
side as well i think he abused hunter i
i i thought about how does the son of
someone so prominent be a crack addict
who's who's got these weird perversions
and i'm like something happened to him
he was traumatized then you look at his
dad sniffing and groping children and
i'm like i think i know where this is
going yeah and everyone says like oh if
that were happening it would come out
you know joe biden's a powerful man
there would be people watching but no
that's precisely why something like that
would never come out
people know if you are crazy enough to
abuse children you'd be crazy enough to
kill people who were going to talk about
it you'd be crazy i think there's enough
there for me there's enough there
without making that supposition and when
you see the film there's enough there to
say what did happen let people make
their own decision because that then
it doesn't it i i think sometimes it
doesn't help us
bring people into the tent because let
them say oh my god make the supposition
and let them come up
i'm not saying i know for sure about
anything but just the idea that like if
the elites are abusing children it would
come out for sure like no they would
have so many methods of covering
epstein yeah exactly
people didn't believe that it was too
crazy when alex jones was talking about
they're like he's crazy there's no way
that's happening did you see the trial
where the lawyer asks jones and he's
like so you believe that you know
epstein or no no he's like you believe
that there's a cabal of like elites that
are trafficking children and he goes you
mean like what epstein did with the
clintons yeah yeah i threw that in there
when they were berating him for other
things and people
people made a thug life video with the
sunglasses come on
wasn't there something weird in biden's
daughter's diary yes
showering together but there's a bigger
question why did the fbi go after a lost
diary yeah she's a private citizen right
she's not in government and it wasn't
legit right is russian disinfo too right
that wasn't a real diary why was it to
protect the incontinence
i don't know
but what i what i can say is something
is wrong when the fbi says a diary of a
private citizen is of national security
a little girl a little girl's diary well
i mean how old was she when she wrote it
because i thought it was like 11 or 14
or something i don't know so this is
just a a 50 cent piece of paper
and the fbi had to get it well
so now you gotta wonder there's nothing
else to do
she wrote about taking showers with joe
right
there was something alluded to that that
and she said probably inappropriate or
something like that yeah there was that
was again alluded to i don't know i
didn't read that i'm just the hair say
of it there was things to that your
audience
can tweet us and or
remember when uh joe broke his foot or
whatever because the dog
in the shower or something like that
that was unbelievable what is going on
you know what what's interesting about
this movie and tim you've been talking
about this a lot this week on your show
about how you got to start with the art
and this is what really drew us in at
breitbart we've always wanted to
distribute movies and get into this
entertainment business to lure people
into your right-wing world
well i i i will say it flat out yes
absolutely but you don't do it just by
starting with the politics and then you
try to see if we can put something
together no you start with the
aesthetics you take robert who's been
had a byline of breitbart since 2009
knew andrew were friends but he travels
the world
performing frank sinatra songs he's made
movies in the past he is a household
name in a household face for his acting
career that's the type of guy we want to
see make a movie and the movie is
hilarious it is so many facts in it it's
so exciting to watch it is it hits you
in the face it's like a fever dream at
times there's really good looking people
in it it's really fun and then also it
does layer in all of that stuff that if
you're not listening to a show like this
or reading breitbart or listening to our
shows then you're not getting that
information in the same way to him with
what you're doing with your music which
is you're just making music i loved when
you read earlier this week and i'm going
to flatter you a little bit but this was
so good you were reading super chat and
someone hating on on your music and and
you said
they were reading something like it was
the worst song they ever heard and you
said well maybe it is i don't know i
made a song you're very honest about it
but i i made a song i put it out let's
let people evaluate it i love that
approach so much i think andrew would
love that approach because you you
create the art let the art be what it is
and let people talk about it let people
discuss it let the daily beast try to
cancel you over it do that that's what
robert's going to put it for me exactly
right i'll say it now that it's thursday
and this is the last day i didn't want
to say anything when we launched but all
of these lefties attacking the song were
pumping the numbers tremendously
and but they really were they were
posting there's like 17 posts on reddit
we have we have an app that tracks
social posts for all of our content yeah
and then i'm just like watching them go
nuts rag on the song and i'm like
95
thumbs up on the people who've watched
it and all they're doing with hating on
it is sharing the video
and it's funny because i was talking to
a friend earlier and i mentioned how the
daily beast said this of of me that i'm
trying to lure people into the
right-wing world and he was saying like
they need something to to fight against
and i was like
they need to hate it because it's their
thing to
do like otherwise what do they have to
talk about there's nothing right so they
create an enemy they say they hate it
but the reality is they don't really
care can i ask you people are checking
out your music and i'm sorry robert i'm
so this is the thing i'm most passionate
about people are checking out your music
because of this stuff and they're
realizing it's good they're going to
check out this film because they read
articles like like the guardian that
wrote
uh that wrote guys stop trying to make
hunter biden conspiracy theories happen
that's a direct line from they haven't
seen the movie and they're already
trying to cancel it good music is
subjective we were listening to the
billboard hot 100. so all these lefties
come out and they're like this music is
dated it's unless lizzo makes it then
it's always good no matter what it says
i was doing it so they said it's dated
and i'm like kate bush is number five on
the billboard 100 it's like what does
data even mean yes but um so we started
listening and we started playing the
song sun roof it came so we're listening
to the radio like the streaming radio in
the car and sunroof by nikki your came
on and it is a teeny bop i'm driving the
sunroof or something like that and i was
like is this what they want is this what
they want me to do i'll do it i swear
we're gonna make a song called is this
what you want and it's going to be pop
and we're going to be bopping around at
a club and the lyrics are going to be as
vapid and as boring as possible and i'm
like no look man good music is
subjective some people think zeppelin
was the epitome of good music some
people think the beatles were some
people think it's ccr some people think
nah man the 90s the 2000s the 2010s
everybody has their taste and they're
allowed to have it don't know don't care
i like some music i don't like other
music a lot of people really love
nickelback not for me but hey they were
a number one for four weeks in a row
that is an amazing feat so good for them
if i put out a song it's because i write
music and not everybody has to like it
right and i and and it is what it is so
i just want to say on this
i thought we'd get like 100 a couple a
couple hundred thousand hits on it it's
at like a million something in on the
streaming services we're couple like 100
plus thousand or whatever uh the sales i
think are over 10k or something like
that and then i'm like oh that's really
cool man i really appreciate that people
are supporting us if if 100 people liked
the music i'd say okay we've put out
cast castle and we've gotten a certain
amount of fans for it we put tales from
the inver inverted world we got some
fans for it chicken city's got fans none
of these things are like time magazine
front page
uh you know content and no one cared
about any of those things
but this song actually took off and
people liked it and they reacted with an
inverse reaction of if people are liking
it we have to hate it with it with an
equal amount of force
i just want to be yeah because we say
right wing a lot
and
i think they might say okay what is
right wing
you know the definition of right wing
and left to me i love this country my
grandpa concerning
my grandparents came from sicily in
naples the new york times said the
italian was lower and dirty than the
negro in 1906.
there were 18 in 1886 there were more
lynchings of italians than anybody else
12 15 sicilians were lynched in new
orleans in 1886.
now
when you say right wing and you say
they came to this country
their first
they were speaking italian my first
language was listening to italian but
they said in the home speak of the
english
raise the flag my grandfather came in
went into the u.s infantry critically
world war one critically wounded twice
my dad world war ii my uncle's the
battle of midways my dad's ship was
torpedoed he was in the water three days
every memorial day veterans day
the flag was raised he put on his navy
uniform
there was a patriotic
in the air
we loved our country there was something
in the air
and they have taken it away
and that's not right wing
we're not right wing we're americans
there should be no left and right there
should be americans and the whole idea
of america first this is what we have to
keep bringing up the idea that there was
a man and i want to bring him up quickly
william harvey carney you've got black
history month william harvey carney was
a was a a black slave
who fought in the civil war for the for
the for the for the union
the guys holding the american flag was
shot up and the flag was about to hit
the ground and he picked it up before it
hit the ground
and he marched with the flag and he got
critically wounded himself several times
he got to safety he gave the flag off he
said the old flag never hit the ground
boys
he then
became in the
1870s and 80s he became part of the
first post office postmaster and got the
medal of honor in 1903. has black
history month ever talked about william
harvey carney do you know the the legend
of the uh the american national anthem
how it was written
when he's saying uh the bombs bursting
in air gave proof of the night the flag
was still there the idea was that you
know he's on this ship yes and the
american flag was the fort was being
bombarded and every time a bomb would
explode the flag would be illuminated
and what was happening was every time
damage would be taken the flag would go
down someone would run up and prop it up
and then die holding it and in the
morning when they came back seeing the
flag there it was the corpses of the
soldiers who refused to let it fall who
had kept it up in the end now that's
probably a legend but it's a brutal
story of like refusing to let the flag
fall well that was william harvey carney
now we got this guy copper nick kneeling
and people spitting on the flag and
desecrating america look at every
country in the history of civilization
has gone through difficulties they've
had slaves they've had uh wars they've
had everything are we going to go back
to the beginning of time and go into
egypt and saudi arabia and uh
wales everywhere so you've got to stop
the nonsense what's going on and our
politicians are feeding into it we're
americans
this is a great country we have freedom
we're blessed with a country not
right-wing it's not right-wing it's not
alt-right it's not left i mean
it's marxist
and america first in freedom here's what
we have
we have
traditionally in this country a left and
a right at some point in this blob of
left and right-wing politics
a a budding occurred and a blob of the
left flop schlopped off
and grew and became its own political
sphere that calls itself the left but
there is still a left and a right if ben
shapiro and i were to sit down and talk
hard policies i would be left of him and
we would disagree on many things and we
would agree on certain facts and studies
but our opinions on how they should be
handled be slightly different
because there's a left and a right
traditionally in this country but this
weird cell that's been growing and and
expanding that believes it is the left
is actually just a cult they're not left
what about giving a child a sex change
is inherently a left-wing policy
position it's not it is an ideological
position but they call it the left and
that's why everyone else is right wing
that's why they say tim fool's a
far-right youtuber it's like bro i'm
like pro progressive tax and pro-choice
but that's right-wing now because it's
expanding and its sphere of influence is
expanding however i do think it is it
has begun to lose the big news that that
uh came out earlier or the other day was
that gutfeld has surpassed colbert in
the writings
now a lot of people are going to act
like that's no big deal on the left they
don't want to admit that they're losing
but when late night
you know the night late night show
whatever things are called are now less
relevant than a cable news channel that
started in the 90s you are losing your
cultural influence and that matters that
means we're winning well they they they
have denied look they come out of los
angeles and new york these talk show
guys and you got the cobra guy you've
got the other two guys
and they refused to talk about
the epidemic of homelessness and crime
in those cities it's astounding to me
they'll talk about everything else but
they won't say in their own backyard
because the elites
don't give a red
look at
the when you go on to a movie set
and we were talking about this earlier
yeah with somebody with uh sean spicer
actually sure when i go into movie sets
the crew
they'll be doing the makeup or the hair
or the guy putting the lights of the
microwave men thank you we're with you
the crew the workers
the people that are running this country
but there's a comic
that shows a man burning a woman at the
stake and he says just so you know i
agree with everything you said right and
that's what it is
these are the you know what i i there's
i can respect to a certain degree that
people are are
are struggling and stuck but it really
is not a compliment for someone to
whisper i agree with you yeah no no i
hear you i hear you but they're there so
we have to give them the courage we have
to find out how to inspire them to speak
up culturally
to have these cultural warriors we have
to speak up this is what i've had a big
argument with a very close friend of
mine like a brother
i won't mention the name i won't mention
what it was about
he has a some platform
and he's had people on but he won't have
me on because i'm a
it would expose
it would expose
the the thing think about that and so i
said but but you agree with me he goes i
know i says but unless
we all start to speak up
what you're talking about is gonna we're
gonna be lost
we've got to take
they've got a whole lot of emotional
reasons to hate the left you know these
people have kept them away from their
families through all the covid stuff
gas prices people getting fired from
their jobs it's been horrific for people
but they don't have a whole lot of
emotional reasons to love the right
trump gave people that for a bit he was
a
obviously this big populist voice it was
about america yeah he was giving us
america but he would amp people up
emotionally right and this is something
i was talking about a year ago where i
was saying you know feelings don't care
about your facts we've been saying it
the wrong way this whole time i'm so
with you on that feelings motivate
people you tell someone a kid falls off
a boat and you tell them they have one
one out of 100 chance of saving them
they're going to jump in every time
because they love their kid they're not
going to be motivated by the numbers you
give them and that's why i love being a
bunch of artists yeah i don't think i'd
see this i'll tell you a story right
there's a there's a crazy story that was
actually not that long ago where a guy
was at the uh uh yosemite i think or the
other where where's the hot springs at
is that yellowstone yeah
yellowstone yellowstone and so he opens
his car and his dog jumps out and runs
full speed towards the hot spring and he
yells at it no stop and it won't listen
he runs after it the dog jumps in the
hot spring and starts screaming so he
takes his shirt off and they tell him
you can't go in and he's and he's like
like hell i can't and he jumps in and
immediately goes help
they pull him out he dies
he didn't care that he was going to jump
into a boiling vat his dog was already
dead but he loved his dog and didn't
think twice
there's another story of a guy who
there's a video of this i think he runs
up to his house on fire and the fire
department's there and he runs up and
then the firefighters are yelling at him
and then he like just runs past him and
then runs out with two dogs yeah people
are motivated by their emotions
there was an article and i wrote an
article in the washington times
our pets are family too and it was about
and this was in the 80s when there was a
thing with there were street muggers
that mugged an old couple beat up the
woman took their money
hurt them
and my supposition was and then this was
in one spot and
this the passerbys did nothing
there was another in dc
where there was someone on the roof on a
ledge
and the people down to stay stay help
him help him let's get him help
what's the difference in the scenarios
one was human being the other on the
ledge was a dog wow really so i said
that if
these kids that mugged these women never
had an animal to love
and i said our animals help us be more
human that's so true in a certain way
and i said and this was in the 80s i
wrote this on the washington times
i mean yeah i wrote it in the 90s but
how interesting is that that we
you know
that story going back to you that the
guy who ran in for his dogs i mean can i
go to the bathroom
you don't got to ask you just go and do
it
but you got to put your hand up first
and then actually lydia has to give you
the permission yeah that's true i do
have to give you yeah you need to pass
also go ahead
there's a pass of course so but i think
that i'm a little black built on this
too because i think that it's too late
to just sit around and whisper to robert
when robert's your makeup chair it's
just those days are over yeah we need
people to be outspoken and you don't
have to be mean about it you don't have
to be
if that's not your voice find your voice
but you do have to be out there and be
vocal and say actually i don't think the
lockdowns are that great i don't think
we should amass kids all that much like
just start with something basic to start
with well you know i liked abortion when
it was safe legal and rare why is it
third trimester fourth trimester like
what
yeah birth just start with something
like that and see how you received but
not even that i said you don't even need
to say anything other than
oh i don't know that sounds kind of
weird
that's it someone comes to you and they
say something like
you know i i think we should be giving
children sex changes you go oh i don't
know that sounds a little extreme that's
it yes and they'll say are you
transferring like i have no idea what
you're talking about dude i just right
i'm confused just chemical crack
castration it can't just don't you're
not gonna go that far like i thought i
was a dog when i was five yeah really
talking about it
for surgery
all right before we go to super jets can
i say because we've been having this
conversation myself and my husband
because i made the supposition that
facts do care about your feelings or
feelings don't care about your facts
yeah something that benchmare talks
about a lot facts don't care about your
feelings i think this is why the right
is losing it's because they ignore the
fact that feelings exist and are very
important because like you're talking
about how people jump into the freaking
hot springs after their dogs we had a
dog die this year and i think robert's
right that it really makes people more
human to have to care deeply about a
creature like that ben shapiro is wrong
he's wrong he is wrong
do care about your feelings very much
let me let's no no so we people have
said facts don't care about your
feelings yes but feelings don't care
about your facts but facts are
manufactured by people based on their
emotions and i don't mean literal
literally i mean in the world of
post-modernism they claim facts but
they're really fabricating they're using
sophistry to assert what they claim is a
fact when it's not so when you get them
coming out saying donald trump staged an
insurrection they would tell you it's a
fact and it's based on their feelings
yes so people believe the facts quote
unquote facts they're receiving
are true when in fact they're just
manipulations of emotion we just watched
the whole speech that was pure feeling
and emotion and platitudes presented as
these are the facts this is what's going
on in our country the violence violence
violence finally said violence like six
times what because one trump supporter
got killed by law enforcement on january
the sixth like that's it like that's the
basis that's what the first the violence
was
three years of violence what the
violence was in this
it's not in portland they just shot and
killed a guy i mean it's it's they they
attacked an old man in a van yeah let's
go to super chats it is time if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
we have a members only show coming up at
about 11 p.m and if you'd like to help
us lure people into our right wing world
today is the last day where they track
the ratings for song releases for us
because we released on friday so if you
really do
want to support us the link in the
description below at band camp you can
buy the song only ever wanted for 69
cents and uh if we get enough sales
maybe we'll chart and have a bigger
cultural impact and then freak the left
out a little bit more because they're
just nuts um but this is the last big
push so we appreciate your support you
better get that song
or i'm gonna haunt your nightmares oh
man
all right all right let's read some
super chats we got um
dakota stanton
and matthew hammond are both asking
about starting atlantis dakota says mr
davi did you enjoy your time on stargate
i did absolutely the crew was terrific
the writers were great the cast was
terrific we had a wonderful time we shot
it in vancouver
yeah no way yeah we shot it i was there
and stopping grounds yeah uh it was a
lot of fun
um and the the show around the world
people appreciate that and i love
playing augustus collier i think you
could have done more with him i need to
watch atlantis because uh i watched sg-1
and it was amazing yeah absolutely just
phenomenal yeah so i need to watch
atlantis did you ever play the game halo
after narrating it
my kids did you never played it yourself
never played it never played a video
game in your life
i dabbled like this a little bit you
know what i mean i i i i for two which
one two minutes uh you know i don't know
what is it
it is i forget the name my son i have a
21 year old boy who's okay you know
that's great i'll give you a pass you
should play halo yeah
no all a lot of military guys
i mean so many people told me hey halo's
off you know favorite game and but i was
you know no no
i always listen to any good let's go to
super chat stephen a says thanks for
putting your new song on bandcamp i
purchased it as soon as i found out
being drawn into a right-wing world was
never so much fun
mission accomplished my plan is working
oh that's terrifying like it's so insane
that it's like a joke
robert no joe joe biden impersonation to
be like i made a song
i hope it's good oh and then he pooped
his pants i put my parents
okay well you know getting back to my
son hunter you can get it
myselfhunter.com you can pre-order it
now great cast john james plays joe
biden
does a great job of it uh not
uh
it's not a parody it's not a it's a
performance it's really a performance
lawrence fox is incredible
uh as as hunter and uh gina carrena who
plays the
uh secret service agent has a in a very
interesting way she reminds me of a
a modern-day different kind of laura
mccall
because she has that saucy
insolence that's right
posted a meme
that was like hey we shouldn't hit our
neighbors so they cancelled her the real
issue was they knew that she wasn't
going along with the agenda and they
needed justification
she's working just fine let me tell you
about this tennis player
everyone talks about why he was canceled
well i was in serbia filming the the
my son hunter film
when trump won there were banners all
over serbia i met
the tennis player pizzeria outside the
pizzeria
and
but what people don't remember
is in 2020 he came out saying i'm
supporting donald trump oh really so
this thing this is the most famous
athlete in the world basically
and i think part of this whole
thing could be a a
retaliation yeah interesting asheboro
says holy crap it's special agent
johnson
no relation
what is it what show is that from was
that die hard die hard the best
christmas movie on it
oh my god
everybody
it is a christmas movie just like saigon
a slick
but it was released in july or something
wasn't it yeah yeah yeah but it became a
christmas film because of
yeah i just didn't in london i just they
just did a screening of
uh die hard in london my myself and john
mcternan went the director i gave a
little concert there and at the end of
my little set i
sang let it snow with the audience
to ensure that it is a christmas movie
and my family thanks them because the
residuals around christmas
you know for me it was a wonderful life
yeah there's other christmas movies but
this to become a christmas movie i i
love it
it's a christmas movie
i i think so um and and whether people
want it to be or not it's stupid it is
like we have memed it to be at the very
least totally on christmas we love to
watch die hard and this christmas watch
it because
davi's on-screen entrance is one of the
best in all of cinema it's unbelievable
you laugh with my i got a story
so i was very close friends with
schwarzenegger back in the day when we
did raw deal together and we were just i
didn't know him and then we did right
deal and became very close friends and
we used to go to
i worked out with him when i was a 32
inch waist and 22 inch arms every day
would work out
and uh so we go to a screening of die
hard and uh we're sitting at 20th
century fox
and i'm sitting here and arnold's i'm
sitting here and arnold's sitting here
and we're watching the film and it's
just it's
i mean incredible first time seeing it
and arnold goes over my command he goes
who's in charge here not anymore me
because this is fantastic you're
fantastic in this i love it it's
fantastic great entrance this is great
and he's watching the film like this
enjoying the movie and as
the fbi guy starts to become a little
stupider
the look on his face is one of what the
heck is going on here and he looks over
there what are you doing you either what
the hell with you i said arnold it's not
me it's the script
he took it you know he was wrapped up
into the it was a very funny moment yeah
all right waffle sense it says where is
lauren's paper cup i just finished it
and threw it out
i've been keeping it on the download
trying not to be a bad influence all
right yeah what was in the paper cup
what is this island park 17.
it's scotch i just they try to bring me
nice uh cups but it's you have a drink
bourbon
i've had i've tried we've got burgers
let me give you i had my first
drink
alcohol i had wine as an italian but my
first hard drink i'm filming with frank
sinatra in 1977 in little italy amazing
at a
and we're in a social club at two
o'clock in the morning
and i'm sitting there
up against this radiator and i'm
thinking to myself my first film with
sinatra
and he's at the bar with the guy great
actor harry guardino another guy named
martin gables who was married to arlene
francis people don't know these names
but they're big names
and a couple of other interesting
characters and
sinatra
does a double take
and he goes robert have a drink i don't
drink mr sinatra you don't drink you're
fired i'll have what you're having oh
wow he says get over here so i come to
the bar it gets a battle
uh jack daniels
bucket glass
two lady fingers of jack
four ice cubes the rest water he says
this will be your drink it'll get you
where you want to go to without getting
you hurt
and after twenty after five rehabs i'm
still drinking the jet no
i digest of course but it's a good drink
because it's watered down and you know
you can sip it and it's enjoyable yeah
but we all got a had a drink with frank
sinatra's story too so yeah everyone has
to say that's so
i got a better story than that but i
won't tell her oh boy chris van der says
you can't do that no that's one way all
right you want to hear it absolutely you
can't should we save it for the members
only portion whenever you want to you
tell me this is you yeah cause that's
that's an epic tease remember well that
is
i love it
because that's the that's when you can
be not family friendly and uncensored
and well it's not a censoring thing but
tune in
to get the story about now we're talking
about uh it's very interesting we'll ask
you a bunch of the stories yeah yeah
yeah well this is the cd it's not
actually it's a it's not un it's not
well it has a it's not that cd it's it's
really quite
uh
his sensitivity he talks about his
sensitivity so we'll uh we'll put attack
and that we'll save it for the members
only let's read some more super chats
yes alien baby says corn pop was just
protecting the children ah three
who knew nurse shark says there was a
speech given on september 3rd 1933 at
nuremberg that this horrific horrific
diatribe resembles more than a little
bit well biden was at that speech
he may have studied it yeah
chris van der says biden's state of the
union address with lauren is hands down
my favorite episode of irl so far this
is awesome love you all keep up the
fight that's the one i got wasted that
was fun no no one else would drink with
me tonight okay it was just i wasn't
about to be solo she had our papi bottle
and she was pouring in a paper cup and i
didn't notice and then halfway through
i'm like are you drinking pappy out of a
paper cup
no no people were super chatting like
yeah what are you doing i i've got a
buddy who i just watched do a shot of
old forrester birthday bourbon which you
gotta stand in line overnight to get one
of those it's like and it's just i'm
just watching like you have no idea what
you just did none of these things mean
anything to us it's just tastes good
tastes bad
is that one good
so i don't like hot flicker i've heard
yeah but i've heard the highland park 17
is really good
i i'm on air at 6am to someone who knows
what they're talking about
6 a.m so so there's no on no no no none
of the drunken state of the unions none
of the drunken save the unions for me
cam girl as soon as says is it just me
or did the speech subtitles actually
outpace this travesty of a speech
correct this is chilling and disturbing
at this point it is the waiting for the
civil war that is the worst to me may
god help and bless us all here's what i
want to say about that maybe they gave
the speech they put it in they gave it
to somebody at youtube or something or
the video was delayed with their
ingestion so but youtube was doing that
was doing the captions those were
youtube captions i'm pretty sure right
well sometimes the cap it's it's odd
sometimes movies will have that delay
you'll have subtitles on the film and
some people catch your head but the
captions were misspelled and wrong oh
they were all misspelled yeah yeah so
the maggie republicans that that was
they they wrote
there's no way they intentionally wrote
maggie republican that was automated
he's automated faster than the actual
speech yeah
i was noticing i was like i know what
biden's going to say before he says it
and it's a live speech that's very weird
yeah unless they were trolling us in
that case hats off right it's pretty
good
on that one right yeah your protesters
out there i wonder if there's like live
streams of the protest that were outside
yeah i wonder what those sirens were for
were there a lot of protests they're
just literally there's a lot yeah were
there if you have videos and stuff yeah
yeah yeah it was really it was hot but
yeah protests were hot a lot of fjb
chanting a lot of sirens going off
and he really earned it it's normally i
think that stuff's sort of bush league
and but it was such a horrible speech
but uh tim your take that it's sort of a
hail mary that's i'm looking at my
breitbart newsroom right now and that's
that's that this speech is assigned
desperation like that's the consensus
out there yeah he's screaming is
dangerous i pray i pray well look uh uh
um
you know are you guys familiar with
people's pundit of course so uh he's a
pollster he's a data data journalist
data journalist
he was showing some data that uh trump
is tremendously outpacing biden polls
and trump is over performing relative to
other republicans so they know it they
know this is their this is their last
leg and there's nothing they can do when
the republicans take and take the
midterms i can't wait
we have to hope that the america first
types launched the investigations but
they've already been prepping for
impeachment can i give this speech if
you didn't think the red wave was coming
see i was kind of getting a little more
skeptical but why would you do i i have
something i need to report do you know
what democrats are making uh their
twitter hashtag right now
democracy it might it might be the worst
thing i've ever seen what is it dark
brandon rises
cringe
and they're saying like he's had enough
of the magazine dude it would have been
like biden should have come out
and he should have just like looked down
and said
i'm coming for you maca republicans and
that would have been actually more
powerful than malarkey terminated oh my
god they've been doing this for a while
though it doesn't work donald dark maga
works because trump actually is kind of
scary yeah because when trump's like
listen i'm going to nuke moscow if you
take ukraine you're like
he might actually do it because
but biden it's like what he's going to
poop his pants and then take his chair i
don't think he's got anything going for
him these memes are so bad too yeah
they've been doing that for a while
though have they okay
they're all tweeting about the speech
they love this speech are they loving
the speech they're they're loving the
violent rhetoric they're loving how much
the nation is being divided they're
loving just dehumanizing but that's good
that's very clarifying because they do
hate us it's not just how dark brandon
is the only one who hates but you see
that's all a cultural that's all a
cultural uh signal the way they're doing
those memes and everything else um
it's all uh
triton 54 says blessed were the days we
held in vain this is a line from the
song will of the people and uh for those
that aren't familiar
it's the portion of the song where the
dictator is on his knees saying his last
words
begging for a way to go back to when the
days were peaceful but uh the good old
days they could not they could not
maintain and so uh in this reference
seeing that i'm like
it kind of feels like it fits joe biden
is up there panicking
saying
you know please
please don't let them win
this can't be
i think i think they know that the
republicans are going to win in 2022 and
2024 and then
dark dark maga
are you familiar with the dark maga
stuff no the trump supporters many trump
supporters saying that trump should just
go full revenge retribution using the
full force of government and just
arresting and investigating and
you know what man i don't even have to
look at it that way i'm just like when
the republicans win they better start
the impeachments in the investigations
yes when donald trump wins in 2024 he
needs to immediately use all of his
authority and powers to start
investigations he needs to just purge
the doj and bring in good people who
want accountability it's not about
revenge it's about we need
accountability that's it he wanted to
work with people trump he really did
this is a guy that wanted to work with
people he was trying to
at the core of him is a a wanting of
likeability of acceptance
at the core of him uh i i would love i
would love your two's take because a lot
of my audience are you know registered
republicans and uh plenty that aren't
but you guys are not really republican
per se and and it is do you have faith
that the current crop republican
leadership will bring the heat will give
the investigation but isn't this a huge
point isn't this one of isn't this one
of the biggest points we can make right
now and you're seeing even rick scott
calling out mitch mcconnell today which
thank god thank god people are realizing
that the republican establishment
they're they're going to disappoint
again and we're on the brink of just
handing them control again but i think
we've seen um
what's really freaking out biden is that
liz cheney lost
joe kent won carrie lake won those are
those are those are what about this
alaska woman
well you know
voting the rank choice that was kind of
the take in our newsroom was the rank
choice really is what but explain that
explain that how that helped the
democrat win i i don't i don't i i gotta
admit i don't fully have my mind wrapped
around it but the idea that i heard is
that in uh first pass to the post vote
the way we normally do elections if you
get 50 democrats and 50 republicans and
then they all vote
let's say you know a few of them don't
care and don't vote you end up with 47
for a democrat 48 for republican
the way it works with ranked choice
is that you've got sarah palin and
you've got a democrat and that so you've
got a maga candidate an establishment
candidate and then a democrat the
democrats will rank their choice for
number one as the democrat but the
establishment republican for their
number two choice if they lose
preventing maga republicans from winning
i don't know if that that mattered in
this instance because it came down to i
think just sarah palin right it was
sarah palin and this other democrat
woman yeah the other woman won yeah
yeah yeah and i think it was just
because she didn't get nearly
anything close to a majority of votes
but because of the way the system and
it's brand new this is the first time
they've done this oh so this is a new
thing yeah it's a new thing and this is
this is where i'm but this kind of
proves my point because my my point is
are the republicans do enough to protect
themselves particularly in purple areas
they're not and they're not making this
is how biden won versus hillary clinton
is the democrats change the rules so
they could essentially legally cheat not
cheat like like i i don't buy into the
vote flipping algorithms of voting
machines overseas you know owned by
china in germany all that stuff you mean
procedural stuff procedural stuff and
they did it right under article but this
is in big tech of course the pr the big
tech stuff i think is what we really
need to be
paying attention to obviously amen
zuckerberg came out in flat out said the
fbi came to him and you can't tell me
the fbi has a whistle the whistleblowers
come out saying they were told not to
investigate hunter biden and then they
went around the same time they go to
zuckerberg and they're like oh watch out
for this stuff it's like come on dude
they were interfering and we all know it
you know i i did a tweet a few weeks ago
about 200 000 views just me on the
camera going hello blah blah blah blah
and it was about the gop again once
again
not being able to come back how come
during this idea of
the january 6th insurrection
trial
aren't we we're a country divided
we've got 74 million people that
disagreed with the election
or more
we have
a house and senate that are basically
neck and neck with a little edge here on
the other side
why can't all these other guys get
together and have a town hall meeting
televised
on any network they want
discussing what was going on and
counteracting the insurrection right
right why did they not do anything like
that this is what they don't do on every
single issue they have let down the
american people and we got to hold these
people accountable what are they
protecting what are they playing why
couldn't they do that all right we gotta
we gotta we're gonna do a 180 on the
subject matter wolf on the plane says
robert can you still sing the italian
aria you sang in goonies and is there
anything special or you remember from
filming it oh well goonies was a great
time it was
six months of shooting all those actors
you know uh
josh brolin and sean aston and man you
know
amazing it was just a great time on the
set
you had dick donna who recently passed
who was a great person
uh steven spielberg produced it and did
all the second unit shooting frank
marshall did all the third unit shooting
and um
by with a script by chris columbus
and uh
the scene when i feed sloth and i start
to sing the unoffered
that was never in the script
but i knew that i was doing this film
with a big pirate ship and kids and
everything else and i said how the hell
am i going to you know make
make something noisier beyond being you
know going from a to z with the
fertilities i said so i said to stephen
and dick donald says i'd like to make
him a frustrated opera singer because
i'm a counterfeiter i said well that's
artistic counterfeiting has an artistic
edge yeah and he looked at it he had a
line how am i supposed to create without
without with with this smith
smithsonian piece of
garbage and i said that was a key all
right i said so i want to sing
and he has to listen to me for his
supper because the way it was was i put
the trade down he'd go reach it and i
we're very vanilla yeah so i sing you
and i sing this song and he starts to
scream and that's when i say hey you see
you're ruining it you're ruining it you
know what i think yeah
and and so that's where and then they
love that and we then put it throughout
the thing amazing but they hid the
pirate ship from us oh you didn't know
and so we didn't know they wouldn't let
us see the pirate ship it was on the
biggest sound stage at warner brothers
which is an underwater sound stage
and when i tell you that we all then saw
this pirate ship for the first time
and it was bigger than life-size because
i did christopher columbus the discovery
with brando and those ships were small
yeah they needed compared to this pirate
ship that they built and it was a shame
that they dismantled it because it would
have been a ride um yeah oh wow yeah so
so i i heard that that the the the
reactions were like were real when they
yes
you mean when they saw the pirate ship
yeah yeah he saved it for that moment to
have them
you know see that that thing and going
down the slide and everything else dick
was great with the kids as a director
and all they were all terrific and uh
you know corey feldman and quan and
kerry green and martha plimpton
you know just a great cast
it was fun it was a lot of fun all right
joey pants who plays my brother right on
marcus pinson this is kind of brutally
says on one 922 was shot in the spine
and paralyzed the fbi fabricated a case
raided my home and came to intimidate me
in the hospital now using the open case
to harass and deny me care access please
help oh
man that's brutal i don't know what one
9 22 on january 9th oh
this guy this is not the sixth the ninth
yeah the ninth
man that's crazy i don't know sorry you
hear me go fund me yeah
let's grab some more super chats
messlinger says goonies never say die
absolutely man the goonies what year was
that 86 86 right yeah i was i think i
was just alive
how old were you then i was born in 86.
no kidding
that hurts let me tell you right now but
do i look my you were filming before i
was alive that's right classic what
month was it released you know
i believe it was july so okay you know
maybe
yeah i was i was yeah a few months old
yep you were a little baby yeah your
parents may have taken you to see it
there you go uh timmy look i don't know
maybe
when is the first time you saw goonies
i can't remember it's it was it was the
year i was born so probably when i was
like
a few months old or a year or whatever
no but i'm saying that you remember it
i don't know maybe when i was like seven
six or
seven you're a friend
30 or 40 times in my life you know so
yeah i don't know because like you go to
a friend's house and the parents would
put it on and stuff like that i was in
italy i did a concert i was the on the
italian version of the voice
and um the host was a guy named jayax
who was the jay-z of italy
a big big star rapper star he was one of
the uh the you know judges and places
and i was just the guest artist ariana
grande was the week after me you know we
sing a song talk
and he loved goonies he had tattoos of
goonies
and he said to me he says
italy is the
we are the goonies of europe
he said and he says it was more
important to him than war and peace
goonies wow
interesting that he said that you know
and a lot of people said like who asked
me today and i said it was the doc oh
the sebastian gorka great sebastian
garca he talked to me about goonies what
made it lasting i says because it's the
dr zhivago of children
because their houses are going to be
taken away from them
and these kids not have to find a way to
get the house you know in a certain
strange way because this has been on my
mind because i'm afraid that they're
going to come after our properties
i really am scared of that
when you think china is buying all our
farmland bill gates is buying our
farmland
now i don't know if this is true but
people keep telling me this intel people
that china
wants to buy the panama canal
oh yeah that's that's they tried
building the nicaraguan canal and that
failed yeah it would have destroyed the
largest like the largest natural aquifer
in the region it would have been
decimated do you know who bought water
there who bought land there bill gates
millionaires bush one two
bill gates is the largest individual
owner of farmland but that's not a lot
of farmland relative to the amount of
farmland no but the aquifer bush tube in
nicaragua bought the aquifer in 2008
under his
family's name
china water rights which has enough
water for a hundred years fresh water
to take care of the population china was
trying to compete with the panama canal
they wanted to build through nicaragua a
massive system and then ultimately it
fell through because it would have wiped
out the water and but there they've got
the was the belt and road initiative
yeah so they're expanding into africa
and south america oh local they're
they're they're colonizing and we track
latin america and africa a lot at
breitbart partially because of this
because we're constantly thinking about
china and it is they are trying to
colonize the planet and parts of the
world you might not be reading about
they're there they're trying to be there
as much as they can and they get people
hooked on their cheap infrastructure etc
yeah well people forget that china has a
much longer memory than we do in the
west especially when it comes to oh
we're going to get you and their plan
and their plans are much much longer
absolutely and they have election cycles
that aren't these four-year trade people
out they can actually you know finish
things they start they're taking the
south china sea i wrote an article
i i wrote a paper that was i was on
homeland security policy institute at
george washington university
for about 14 years
and because of my filming world i went
around the world meeting intel guys and
they would come to me as well and i'd
think tank it
when covert happened
back in february when it started to
happen and they were feeding me
information i did 59 pages
on the origins of covid
there was a
chinese
defense minister former defense minister
of china
called
a chi haitian
who gave a secret speech to the
communist chinese party
in 2003 which he said that
china must think of its population we
have to teach our people to go out
we've got to colonize
we've got to colonize
we've
no longer can use nuclear weapons
because it destroys you can't occupy the
territory so we have to increase our
biological weapon program which we
already have
and then the next year wuhan lab was
built
now the virus
not to talk about it actually started in
saudi arabia in 2012. the virus the sars
virus the bunch of guys got the sars
virus the sars virus they took the dna
of that sars virus
that came from bat to human
they took it they brought it to a lab in
in the netherlands
and then a frank smith who died of a
heart attack in december of 2019
took that stuff to a lab in canada
and that lab in canada they know that
flight it went to wuhan
well who knows this
uh i'll send you the paper and you can
look at it it's 59 pages i'll send it to
you today i i don't i don't you know i
gotta be honest i don't know if we need
all of that you know why
because the virus originated they say
across the street from the wuhan
institute of virology
and uh the bats where it's supposed to
come from were a thousand miles away so
i just think right off the bat it's like
you got a narrative problem there buddy
absolutely from the beginning but i'm
saying that i said this in february i
was i put this i tweeted this 59 pages
one at a time
and no one would pick up on this thing
that it was created in the lab that it
was a a
maybe not done on purpose
but they even had the whole well they
had a
researches in china at it was like south
beijing university or whatever i don't
remember the university was where they
said that people were bitten and peed on
by the bats
and so
look any sane normal person at least
entertains the probability that it's
likely but for the media to come out and
spit in your face and tell your
conspiracy theorists for thinking what
is patently obvious is just nuts
but we're gonna go uh to the member
segment and i'm really interested in
those stories that you got so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have that members only show
coming up it'll be published in just
about an hour if you want to help us
lure people into our right wing world
click the link in the description below
go to band camp and search for only ever
wanted by tim cast you can buy it for 69
cents this is it the last day the last
chance the last shout out if you really
want to help us hit the charts buy the
song i don't know if we will you know it
is what it is but we could use your
support you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
robert do you want to shout anything out
no just mysunhunter.com go there watch
the show you can download it you can
prepay for it now it'll be on
breitbart presents it it was
produced by the unreported stories
society that's anne mcinelli and and and
and phillip mcelr
and it's a terrific film lawrence fox
gina carrana um john james
september 7th you can download it and
own it right on and get the song come on
there's no advertisements here right
yeah yeah get the song it's good well
there are ads on youtube you know yeah
but youtube but not right now we didn't
go hold up and say you know well that is
the ed you know like instead of doing a
normal shadow we shout out ourselves
yeah there you go i appreciate it robert
thank you very much absolutely you want
to shout anything out alex yeah my
sonhunter.com is the most important
thing the september 7th is a big day
breitbart.com i wrote a book came out
last year called breaking the news on
the media was the new york times
bestseller so which is obviously they
don't they don't want those things to
happen given the subject matter uh
that's i'm on siriusxm patriot 125 6 to
9am and we have podcast so a lot of
different places but myself.com if you
only remember one of those if you don't
know that i sing i do the american song
book davi sing sinatra yeah really go to
amazon itunes it charted to number six
when it first came out but it's always
good to bump that thing up and it's good
listen to it
all right you can follow me at lauren
underscore southern on twitter look me
up on the youtubes and do all the things
they said go watch it and you're a
filmmaker too i'm working on one right
now but it's top secret okay
really tell us what it is i don't know
tim well i'm pretty sure
most people
can figure it out right now
just by you saying that so i'm wondering
if people are going to mention in the
chat oh sorry
i'm not saying they're not supposed to
know i'm saying like
lauren southern is here what does lauren
southern do yeah tim poole has talked
about doing things with the company that
are currently in production i wonder why
lauren is in dc oh that's serious that's
fun
i'm a little dense i had to put that
together quickly
well for the people who watch the show
consistently and they know that we've
been talking about doing documentaries
and then lauren shows up it's like kind
of obvious that we're working with
lauren undocumented no
yeah anyways
buy the song watch the movie watch my
movie when it comes out there's nothing
more important that you can be doing
right now than supporting art
art that isn't communist that's it do
not be afraid to speak up
it's imperative you speak up it's
imperative that you become cultural
warriors tell your friends
don't give up don't whisper as they said
earlier
stop the whispering yeah bite and
whispers you don't want to be like i'll
be like
don't be like
100 for sure thank you all creative
people so much for coming robert it was
delightful to meet you alex as well
lauren is always a delight to have um
fun thursday evening for sure you guys
can follow me i have nothing to show
just follow me on twitter minds.com at
sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlids.net
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you